[Musique]
alors comment est ce que je suis là et
un enfant de dix mille chinois
quand vous passez du temps de son
géniteur
cette île je regarde de cette absence
selon le délai est aussi soulagé tennis
at il donc faire des pins veut par
exemple - et en faillite est
intéressante dans la conquête dans les
faits de palettes 5 utile est de faire
une réflexion s'est vu à travers la
parce qu'en fait passer par un
changement de société et le fait que
venir le danger plutôt du bois s'en va
entendre un procès à manger le show dont
21 civils et ensuite manufacture par
exemple les tendres et je me disais à
chaque fois des pnj mais qui a décidé
que le café bar à lait de ppr
pourquoi est ce que l'on pouvait pas
avoir de l'ice cream son fils parce que
mon jeu est donc ces questions mon
enfant aux français comme ça je ne suis
dit que puisque je suis raciste
pourquoi ne pas faire une sculpture qui
s'appellerait cafés bars et qui serait
c'est ce que j'ai fait
voyez mais aussi dans ce même
questionnement je me suis le fait
d'abord les enfants par exemple jamais
attardons-nous trifide droits de la
femme du mpla la mer occident était
plein de poissons et même que les
fichiers d'apple était un poisson
congelé en fait on mangeait un bandage
et non et encore une fois je veux donner
pourquoi est ce qu'on fait évidemment on
se rend compte que les poissons qui est
énorme et fribourg et des dessins est
envoyé les siens et y est en marché et
donc les gains de ces poissons et puis
réutilisé par trois chercheurs qui parle
foot est enfin dispo notation moody's
est aussi content d'aller pêcher par
exemple ont jeté des baguettes
il ya des baguettes dans l'autre pour la
célébration le joyeux les bras sont
aussi manger du pain et lorsque j'ai
vraiment besoin de manger du poisson
puisque le bois ou mange du pain et que
cette réflexion et c'est logiquement
attendu notre culture moyenne au bâton
est en fait c'est un congélateur
avec à l'intérieur un mic many many en
passant le franchement mauvais elle
avait atteint des baguettes du cachet du
tout cette somme à gauche mme royant
fait que le clip de marche que j'ai
composées pour nous de veiller à une
avec six visuels de ce nom je n'utilise
pour les jeunes actrices
actu et c'est une étoile dans le ciel
blinis et en fait pour tout lien entre
amiens et les navigateurs polynésie en
fait utilisé cette école pour la table
mais actualise c'est aussi un nom une le
l'enduit de la rue thiers explosion
nucléaire qui a été détourné au calcul
russe est toujours celle de faire des
fondations
le oui au milieu et c'est aussi le nom
d'une série de mondou type d'astres que
j'ai fait pour raconter cette histoire
parce que notre histoire d'après-guerre
et notre culture c'est aussi ça ces
images d'explosion atomique depuis les
années 60 avec ça fait dix ans il y
avait aussi eu goldorak dessins animés
et dans le total moniste principal j'ai
répondu à ta luxe donc cette
conflagration de deux de nos contrées et
s qui m'ont inspiré 1 et 6 2
donc c'est dommage une façon un peu
photographique 26 en fait à la main et
pour un peu vraiment montrer la 7e ces
images le missile aller aussi à la fois
qu'ils se sentent à l'autre en plus j'ai
fait est ce ainsi plein en effet lens en
fait et les blocs de de simon qui
semblait plein et conductivité pour
encore moi en fait on y est mis à l'eau
il est là dessus en fait on attache ni
l'heure ni type au mali dans ce contexte
là en fait de travail en fait j'ai
grandi matinale et je vois je voyais et
pendant toute ma faute de simon près de
chez les bulldogs qui n'ont jamais bougé
le cul et je me disais mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cet homme géante qui a un
peu perdu sa fonction fait mais qui du
coup en fait que le sultan bin
deviennent aussi de la place des gens
mais aussi en partie de leur visage le
paysage futur
donc moi qu'est ce qu'un lourd s'était
pas comment est ce que je peux pas de
moi je réponds d'une façon mais au final
je suis justement vide
comment est ce que quelqu'un qui n'est
pas de notre culture ou de votre
quartier
un pays peut-être même un extraterrestre
ont valu pourrait essayer de jeu pour
expliquer ces objets cultuels finalement
à ces personnes là donc je me suis
inspiré par déjà dû signer deux
triangles et j'espère gommer d'ici 24
points le racing s'est forgé puis
appliqué j'étudie donc en fait c'est
quoi
ils s'en iront dessiner d'autres objets
comme des mémoires et aussi je l'avais
bonne augure
comment ça vous dit la vision alors dans
mes ans dans cette partition de citibank
c'est bien j'ai été coriace en soirée
croire mais je pense que je suis jeune
mais j'aime bien aussi pour repeindre
les deux personnes qui sont comme moi
partie de sa culture et avec qui je
pourrais échanger et heavy cgt mais ces
personnes et on s'est dit qu'on allait
se donner un espace pour se rassembler
pour discuter pour avoir justement ces
échanges est fini le compte est séparé
donc on s'est donné le dollar l'idée de
cette vision en lisant pour la polynésie
pendant qq mais aussi pour nos places
qui seront pas seulement créer de la
cité du design et ils dépendent
essayez de le continuer de façon
contemporaine comme j'ai misé et de
d'essayer de mettre en détention
à voir cette nouvelle pratique
face au nouveau paysage ça commente pas
les connaisseurs
parce que on utilise beaucoup d'efforts
pour se parler dans les coller dans les
colonnes de près mais aussi en colombie
on utilise des châteaux et on s est
fatiguant fête est aussi apparu dans les
vêtements en fin de vie et des choix est
donc positive a pour l'instant plaisir
et tout ça ne se présentait aussi une
autre façon donc c'est un peu comme ça
non seulement le feuillage pour à la
fois être paris surmonter mais aussi
caché de pour mieux pouvoir vous
regardez donc le real aussi dans une
partie de les expliquer avec mais bon
lui voulait parler justement de faire de
la boxe elle signifiait sa mort le
pratiquer
qui change mais où s'est fait partie
dans la quotidien c'est beaucoup mais
pas juste les collines accès au site
c'est valence tellement de beaucoup de
goût aussi les gens qui par exemple a en
fait qui des innocents de lever cet
objet pas fui une autre passante et de
se munir évidemment là bien ça
n'intéresse plus forte si évidemment le
fait de pouvoir quelque chose de son
environnement
mais pendant 8 à 6 mais à ceux qui
équipent les ans et que le sublime élise
le temps soir là c'est un travail de la
vidéo est l'un des thèmes traités h et
de cohésion et elle ne la connaissais
pas un plan de vie des duty free fight
dentifrice et couvertures le quine bien
des patchworks et cette idée de cette
couverture une deuxième peau pour lancer
le 23
une sorte d'architecturé et dans l'idée
donc tout d'un coup une recette pour ans
qui devient une toiture devient aussi au
nom de tous les enfants ont pu jouer la
montée avec ses motifs rage vous vivez
vous les voyez d'envoyer la pétanque les
vins tourné à vide sculpture ou quatre
ans les lundi alors qu'il ya aurait volé
e el mundo bâtons de bois
cameron aliens principaux dossiers qui
ont des relations
cette nouvelle religion
et justement à des questions de société
que nous indiquons pauvres comment est
ce que je peux vivre la culture d'état
sont additionnés de tête mais tout en
étant sûrs t'oblige à nautla le bâtiment
pas forcément une pratique artistique de
100 200 barriques
mais je vais essayer de penser
[Musique]
relationnel aux orgies dans l'espace
d'exposition
donc elles montrent le sable et les
morceaux de différents des coups à untel
ou untel tenue qui enfante alors c est
bon sur le caillou et des morceaux de 2
vers la page totalement la fille de
collection quelle place est dans le
milieu des petits cailloux ou assiettes
en fait et pour moi c'était assez
touchants de la suivre dans sa
trajectoire dans le fond qui régale un
peu ses frères noury mériller colonne et
qui font ces îlots où à chaque fois en
fait elle me raconte une petite histoire
donc moi c'est pas dur de découvrir ce
français de pouvoir déjà jetés mais
aussi de la suivre
dans son cheminement intellectuel grippe
et qui va donc compatible donc finir j
je n'ai pas les deux colis n'était en
fait il faut être soit émise et ça veut
dire le libertaire et c'est je viens
voir en pratique personnelle parce que
je me suis dit qu'au cours des combats
la question de une vision de notre futur
et notre culture
je voulais aussi avancé le sens de la
main peut-être aller on avoue et en fait
c'est une ascension du léman où je
m'étais dit que je voulais me
débarrasser moi-même n'est pas son
physique parce que là c'est imprécis et
pendant cette ascension de cette saison
et je vous l'offre pour que puissante
est de vivre dans cette culture
et puis faut faire déborder et google
[Applaudissements]